just like get out and us jordan peele's
newest film nope is packed to the brim
with subtle foreshadowing and small
details before you go to see it a second
or third time watch this to see the
things only true fans noticed in nope
spoilers ahead
nope opens with a piece of scripture
from the book of nahum from the hebrew
bible specifically nahum chapter 3 verse
6. in the bible's new international
translation the verse reads as follows i
will pelt you with filth i will treat
you with contempt and make you a
spectacle there are a couple of
different ways to interpret the meaning
of this verse in the context of the film
and some of them require a greater
understanding of its biblical context
nahum chapter 6 primarily deals with
god's judgment against the assyrian city
of nineveh which is portrayed as a
deeply sinful and debaucherous place at
various points in the old testament as a
result one way to read jordan peele's
use of the verse is as a commentary on
hollywood and its role in modern culture
it's a bad miracle
nope is a movie that deals heavily with
the self-destructive nature of hollywood
how it can change people for the worse
and how it often twists trauma and
tragedy into profit ricky park uses his
dark past as a source of income and
holst ultimately chooses to die because
he's so obsessed with his craft
alternatively the opening scripture
could be read as a foreshadowing of the
aliens attack or simply as a commentary
on the horror genre at large
nope features a lot of references to
aliens from the beginning even before
the flying creature makes itself known
to oj and emerald jupiter's claim the
wild west theme park run by ricky park
evokes a galactic energy with its name
alone the film deals heavily with the
territorialism of animals with the
monstrous alien ultimately revealed to
have staked a claim to the haywood ranch
the name of jupiter's claim foreshadows
that extraterrestrial territorialism
before the creature ever appears on
screen additionally the sign that marks
the way out of the back of the park
reads out yonder which could be
interpreted as a reference to space as
well as a general cowboy phrase whether
intentionally or not it evokes the 1960s
sci-fi anthology series the outer limits
which as a fan of the twilight zone
jordan peele is certainly familiar with
the first proper scene in nope is a
glimpse at the gruesome gordy's home
disaster which is shown in more detail
later on while the full scope of what
happens isn't clear at first the gordy's
home scene features a bunch of little
details that foreshadow the rest of the
film for starters the actual chain of
events at the gordy's home taping
parallels the alien encounter later in
the film pretty directly in both cases a
potentially dangerous creature is used
to turn a prophet by performing in front
of a live audience and in both cases
eventually that creature becomes fed up
and as ricky himself says in the film
hits his limit the irony is only
strengthened by the fact that ricky
himself orchestrates the second
catastrophe with the alien as he's
experienced the horrors of gordy's
rampage firsthand
one of the more curious characters in
nope is angel torres an ordinary text or
employee whose affinity for alien
conspiracy theories brings him into the
thick of oj and emerald's investigation
angel comes off as a relatively frazzled
person at times but he's also clearly
capable of getting the job done when
push comes to shove perhaps that's
because he has the benefit of a passive
stream of income or more specifically a
miniature crypto mining operation set up
in his bedroom after they escape from
the alien creature and the haywood ranch
angel brings oj and emerald back to his
place for a debrief in the background
you can see that he has a rack of what
appears to be processors rigged up to
his computer with multiple fans blowing
on them to keep them cool given angel's
tech savvy nature it makes sense that
he'd try to make a little extra money
via his own personal crypto mine five
stars angel five stars
throughout nope there are numerous lines
and visual touches referring to the eyes
oj quickly learns that the alien is less
aggressive if you don't look up at it a
trick that he learns from working with
horses and yet at the same time there's
an obsession with seeing things in nope
the shot the money shot undeniable
singular
the oprah shot oj emerald and the rest
of the crew repeatedly returned to the
ranch because they need to get the
perfect shot of the alien things only
become more intense after holst the
famous director from the beginning of
the movie is convinced to join their
cause holst is obsessed with landing the
impossible shot of the alien to the
point that he seems to nearly lose all
sense after doing so in the scene where
emerald first reaches out to him about
their mission holst is seen editing
black and white footage of animals with
many of the shots simply being close-ups
of the creature's eyes he then makes a
reference to being famous having all of
the eyes on the world on you being like
a dream that you never wake up from
clearly there's some meta commentary
going on here with peel discussing both
the optics of fame and the eye of the
film director that he himself is and of
course m finally gets the perfect
picture of the alien via the well camera
at jupiter's claim which itself could be
perceived as a massive gaping eye
emerald is first introduced on the scent
of one of antlers holst's projects where
emerald gets to deliver an extended
sales pitch for herself and the haywood
ranch where oj clearly lacks any love
for performance or public speaking
emerald is a natural and she quickly
rattles off the entire haywood hollywood
history a history that she claims goes
all the way back to the first motion
picture ever despite emerald's expert
delivery however she does stumble at one
point and that man is my
great great grandfather great there's
another great grandfather later on we
see why emerald gets the number of
greats wrong toward the end of the film
emerald is seen watching an old vhs tape
featuring the recurring man on a horse
movie in the background her father can
be heard delivering the exact same
speech word for word that she delivers
earlier in the film the reason emerald
makes the mistake is that she learned
the speech by memorizing this particular
recitation from her father and because
her father is one generation older he
only says two greats where emerald
should say three
in keeping with the old school hollywood
films that inspired it nope has an
extended opening credit scene that might
be a bit confusing your first time
through the credits are displayed in
what looks like a cave covered in
billowing sheets with the mouth
eventually giving way to the original
movie of a man riding a horse in reality
the opening credits take place within
the mouth of the alien creature who
terrorizes the haywood ranch because the
alien is believed to be a spaceship for
much of the film this is an easy detail
to miss and yet when the staff and
guests of the star lasso experience are
sucked up into the monster's maw it's
shown to be the exact same as the venue
of the opening credits oj makes another
allusion to the ufo's true nature
following an early encounter with it in
which he tells his sister that he has to
get back to work because he's got mouths
to feed if you know what to look for
these clues foretell the true nature of
the alien before it's officially
revealed though it would be hard to
guess what you're seeing in the opening
credits your first time through nope
the two main characters of nope grew up
on their father's ranch and were taught
the trade of animal wrangling a skill
that probably doesn't get enough love or
respect in pop culture perhaps that's
why jordan peele spends so much time in
the movie emphasizing the importance of
the job yes oj otis and emerald all work
in the field of animal wrangling but the
film's endorsement of that work goes far
beyond its protagonists simply being a
part of it for instance the gordy's home
tragedy might never have happened if the
animal wranglers on set had been better
prepared or more focused on safety oj's
knowledge of animals also ends up being
the key to defeating the alien as he
realizes the trick of keeping one's eyes
averted by reflecting on his time with
the horses by contrast ricky and holst
only seem to view animals as subjects of
spectacle with ricky trying to use the
alien's presence to turn a profit and
holst fixating more on his shots than on
the animals themselves in a way you
could say that nope is one long
cautionary tale about the importance of
treating all creatures with respect
ricky park has a rough time of it in
nope though he seems to be a pretty
successful businessman he's clearly
haunted by the trauma of his experience
on the set of cordy's home his secret
room of memorabilia from the show is
plenty creepy and it features a few
details that make it even creepier for
instance the bloodied shoe from his
presumably dead former castmate is
displayed in an upright position just as
looked to him from his hiding place
during gordy's rampage later when the
star lasso experience is revealed there
are even more remnants of ricky's
horrifying experience the alien costumes
that he has his children wear for the
act look strikingly similar to
chimpanzees which is an interesting
choice given ricky's history with the
animals and of course there's the fact
that he invites his scarred former
gordy's home co-star to his alien
sideshow only for her to be swallowed up
by the creature along with him
few shots in modern cinema are as iconic
or as frequently referenced as the
famous motorcycle slideshot from akira
the 1988 cyberpunk anime masterpiece the
shot has been parodied and outright
mimicked numerous times over the decades
since the film was first released and it
shows up once again during the climax of
nope while racing away from the alien on
the paparazzi's journalist's bike
emerald performs the iconic slide racing
away from the camera and skidding to a
stop in addition to being a reference to
akira the shot is also the payoff to
align from the beginning of the film
when emerald is giving her speech to the
crew of hulse's film early on she closes
by pitching herself mentioning that she
does all manner of creative work around
hollywood and is always available one of
the random skills she mentions is that
she rides motorcycles which obviously
comes in clutch during the final act
as the end of nope approaches the alien
transforms from its traditional ufo
shape into a much more abstract and
bizarre creature the saucer that it once
was expands and billows into a massive
flowing entity somewhere between a giant
squid and a fitted sheet the creature
also reveals a mouth eye or something
else entirely which takes the form of a
small square in the center of the
alien's body all in all it's a baffling
design effectively conveying the other
worldly status of the beast there are a
few things worth noting in the alien's
final form for starters its body takes
on much the same consistency as the wavy
tube men seen throughout the movie
referred to as sky dancers at one point
in the film it also seems clear that the
mouth of the creature is meant to mimic
the shape of a camera lens which makes
it especially ironic that it responds to
anyone looking directly at it by
consuming it no wonder ricky refers to
the creature as the viewers it's also
worth noting that the creature's design
seems incredibly reminiscent of holland
artists the ojansen strand beasts with
their wind powered designs and eerie way
of movement
from start to finish nope is littered
with throwaway lines and visual touches
that tie all the little things into the
greater narrative oj mentions early on
that the first film he ever worked on
with his father was the scorpion king
and that they brought a horse called
jean jacket for the shoot later on oj
names the alien jean jacket and wears
his scorpion king crew hoodie into
battle against it in a way he sort of
becomes the rider in the old horse movie
who he claims as an ancestor racing onto
hulse's crank powered camera just as the
black and white film races through the
opening credits no detail is left to
chance angel wears a t-shirt that reads
earth over a graphic of a dragon and
different phases of the moon even
holst's awkwardly hilarious recitation
of sheb woolies the purple people heater
seems to hold a deeper meaning in a
verse unheard in the film woolly sings i
saw him last night on a tv show he was
blowing it out a really knocking him
dead could this unsung lyric be a
reference to the horrific gordy's home
scene maybe and what about this line
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
on second thought maybe not every detail
in a jordan peel movie needs to be
dissected so extensively but when a
director packs so much into every scene
it's hard not to look for all the little
details that might be hiding there check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]